hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 4 video amazing
Quentin episode 2 tour-de-force
Paul Blackthorne Stephen Amell was
saying after the episode that sometimes
it's more fun for the actors to do these
quiet episodes they call them quiet
because they're not doing like big
Justice League things like it's not a
big crossover episode they're mostly
doing character work Quentin in
particular but just give up for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet I'll
do my top 5 WTF explain Rutina Wesley 's
character because she is a character
from the comic books a real quick
reminder my reverse flash ring for this
week is still going on right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
starting with number 5 meet liza warner
so most of you remember her as Tara from
True Blood I actually liked the
character that she was playing on arrow
way better I wasn't a huge fan of Tara
on True Blood but the character she's
playing from the comics this is this is
really funny her name is Lady cop that's
the actual name of the character now
they're just using the Liza name she's
not really doing this comic book persona
Errol will do that sometimes will
they'll give a character a comic book
name but they'll have nothing to do with
the character in the comics so the way
she exists in this arrow narrative is
she's a dirty cop that was part of the
anti-vigilante task force that Quentin
put together when Oliver came back in
season 1 there was a lot of season 1
callbacks in this episode so she's been
in the city this whole time just as
things have gradually gone to and
now what they're doing is is that are
using their special skills their special
gear their access as police officers to
steal these drugs and make money off of
them and they did name-drop slam that's
the drug they're making on the island in
the flashbacks it's a combination of
heroin and cocaine as far as I know
Rutina isn't coming back again real soon
she might come back in the back half
because I mean she's just a relatively
big actress and she did a great job it's
an interesting character so so she might
come back the same way Huntress comes
back every every once in a while for
special occasions I know everybody's
still wondering where Huntress is that
they'll totally bring just a good dig
out back when she's available
and they have space for her in the
narrative I'd much rather see like Thea
get an amazing story arc to see like for
new comic book characters this season
speaking of getting thrown at the wall
on to number 4 mr. terrific and felicity
try to figure out what the hell is going
on with her mystery text if it wasn't
clear
mr. terrific is working on a number of
projects for felicity most of what they
were talking about in this episode
though was relative to like the glitchy
text that Felicity was getting now
obviously we all know it's the atom we
know it's Ray Palmer trying to contact
her but Felicity is unwilling to listen
to that last message of his so they
haven't started to trace him down yet
they don't know exactly what's going on
so mr. terrific uses part of his comic
book character to inspire Felicity to
get over herself like he kind of slaps
her to her senses you should be happy to
hear something from someone you love who
has died and mister terrific's big call
to action in the comics was his brother
died but also in the world of cool
technology oliver unveils the new arrow
cave call it whatever you want it's
always gonna be the arrow cave to me but
basically it just got all the best new
tech it's just way bigger so they can
accommodate a bigger team you have your
Salmon Ladder you have space for a car
you have Felicity's computer gear we're
just slowly inching towards a Hall of
Justice now
legends of tomorrow they have a really
interesting base of operations it's
gonna be rip hunters Timeship the name
of that is the Waverider which is a nice
Easter Egg for the comics Waverider the
character I'll be talking a lot about
legends of tomorrow next week whenever
Hawkgirl debuts on the flash we could
talk about it then but the big twist is
is that Oliver is using brother Bloods
old campaign office and his old secret
lair underneath his campaign office
which i think is kind of funny now it
seems like the campaign is gonna run for
most of the season and then the back
half he'll probably actually become
mayor so I guess they'll turn this
office into something else after he
becomes mayor but it's not like they're
gonna move the new arrow cave so so they
might just have Oliver continue to work
out of that specific office also in the
world of WTF reveals Laurel takes
Quentin to see Sara for the first time
and he flips out like he's super happy
but then he learns that she has no soul
damien darhk's comment about her not
having a soul kind of throws to what's
gonna be going on with constantine next
week next week will be when constantine
comes to fix her I felt like the follow
up with Quentin you know when he breaks
down crying he has like his Carroll
Pelletier look at the flowers moment
with Sara where he's like you're not
you're not Sara I'm gonna return you to
your final rest that would have worked a
little bit better if the entire episode
had been told from Quentin's perspective
that's kind of what they did with agents
of shield this week then they told the
entire story from Simmons
perspective it was still a great arrow
moment but but I understand they have
all these characters they have to
service you can't just drop all these
storylines for a week just to tell this
one storyline really as good as this
moment was I think his best scenes were
with Stephen Amell he and Oliver just
like just having it out when Oliver
learns about damian darhk-- so that's
what Stephen Amell was talking about
when he said sometimes it's more fun to
do quiet episodes than it is to do the
really big stuff the big action
sequences and finally under my number
one WTF moment
Quentin saves the day the city is not
beyond redemption but we have to start
fixing it by fixing ourselves first
owning up to our own mistakes leading to
all of her roasting the out of
himself in his campaign speech he spends
like a solid two minutes making fun of
all the stupid that he's done so
you know as emotional as the episode is
as much of a roller coaster and as dark
as things get it's a really nice light
weight to end and actually the montage
that they cut to all the different
characters you see damian darhk--
opening that mystery box that's always
such a great device it's very
manipulative you've seen Pulp Fiction
you've seen seven you know all about the
the what's in the box mystery but it's
still so much fun when they do it based
on the markings it looks like it's
something that's just tied to his
abilities
whatever mystery deity that he's formed
this pact with that's giving him this
power but let me know what was your
favorite moment in this episode there
were definitely a lot of setups for
future payoffs look you have damian
darhk-- with the the mystery box sara
busting out of her chains the atom
slowly trying to contact felicity in his
teeny tiny state there were really only
like a few things that threw me off in
the episode Thea for instance is going
from zero to bloodlust in no time flat
but she's able to be super casual in
jokey when she's talking to her drug
dealer here it's almost like none of
what happened last week happened to her
at all like she's completely forgotten
about it I'm still trying to decode the
flashbacks there isn't a really clear
arc right now but the fun thing is is
that when he takes her to that cave
that's the cave that he first went to
when he landed on the island when he got
strained on the island that's what he
says don't eat the red berries because
in season 1 he ate red berries and he
started hallucinating his father so he's
basically giving her all the advice that
he learned the hard way
like he did all the wrong things but I
am really curious that they haven't
revealed what her name is I feel like
it's something big from the comic books
otherwise there'd be no reason
withold her name even on IMDB she's
still listed just as worker and just a
circle back around the damian darhk--
father stuff fathered a father i want to
give you a bit of a WTF here so damian
darhk-- has a daughter somewhere maybe
he put her to final rest again maybe she
still exists somewhere I feel like
that's gonna be floating around for us
to wonder about for the next couple of
episodes I used the thing that was a
good chance that he might be Felicity's
father but the producers like they came
flat out before the episode aired and
said no that's not the case
Felicity's father is another character
who will be a villain and is super rich
who they'll use some time this season
that's actually not not a very big list
I would think calculator would be a good
chance but whoever the villain is it's
not going to be damian darhk-- so I'm
gonna try and get a new trailer a QA
video out later this week they should
post by Friday but why you guys wait for
that you can click here for my agents of
shield video that I posted earlier today
if you haven't seen it yet and you can
click here for my flash episode from
last night king shark for the win so
amazing thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow